real briefly who are the other YouTubers
that are talking about biology and
directly fighting against the
intelligent design stuff and the
creationism stuff yeah um so two people
that I that I like are gut sick Gibbon
yeah she was she was actually first on
my list she's I think she's one of the
best right now that directly addresses
creationism the things that the fact
that she delivers are great um she's
able to cite her claims really well also
she's she's really funny so that helps
yeah um and then also my friend Jackson
wheat I think he does a really good job
of he was second
yeah and I mean I I would say also like
I think rationality rules does a really
good job of putting informational videos
out there the thing is is that he does
what I do which is just calls you when
he when he wants to do that
yeah his stuff isn't so much biology but
it's he's done stuff on creationism
that's from the philosophical angle yeah
yeah he's excellent for that another guy
that
I love trade the explainer have you ever
watched that oh my God yeah trade
explainer is one of my like top three
YouTubers I found out that he followed
me on Twitter really recently and I was
I was freaking out it was great it was
it was a great moment for me Trey is
wonderful his stuff is maybe like six
years ago he went on a big thing with
paleontology he would look at animal
corpses and people thought were
dinosaurs or whatever I need to talk
about what they were really really cool
stuff he has one on the biology of
Avatar yeah like the biology of Game of
Thrones and where he would talk about
you know if these organisms actually did
exist how could they have evolved so
he's really good at pulling in
pop culture stuff and making the science
really funny and interesting because of
that he's he's super good yeah there's
another Channel creation myths just
explores creationism and points out the
claims that are being made and why
they're wrong and then Nature's
compendium is another Channel that I
like and he just does a bunch of stuff
on different fossil organisms and what
they were what we think we know about
them why we think we know those things
and he goes into a lot of detail and he
he does these reconstructed animations
that are pretty cool so and so I have a
couple more people on my list to check
out then anyone else that you would
recommend even podcasts or other than I
mean we talked about Joe Rogan winter
podcasts that you actually listened to I
watched Star Trek at night with my wife
but other than that I just am like
reading non-fiction books uh that's
awesome but no I mean I I really like um
it's not really like debunking
intelligent designer creationist stuff
but I like basically all PBS series
there's so many good PBS produced uh
YouTube channels now and I mean there's
like things like the Hank Green produces
like scishow scishow tangents is a good
podcast
um I think that PBS eons is one of my
absolute favorite YouTube channels and
yeah one of the channels that really
influenced me to be like
hmm so maybe this creationist stuff that
I I was taught you know the evolutionism
is a big lie and they don't have any leg
to stand on they're all just lying like
maybe that doesn't hold up this actually
seems pretty legit for people interested
in like the nitty-gritty of uh
paleontology Darren Nash he's a
paleontologist he has a he has a podcast
I don't think it's still active or it's
really slowly active but he does a
podcast with paleo artist John Conway
where they just talk about different
fossils I would say they're timeless it
doesn't matter that he didn't record it
last week yeah it's just he's going over
stuff about different fossils and
different arguments people have had in
paleontology and it's also they're two
British guys and they just they talk
about they go on lots of tangents but it
it's really fun to listen to them I'll
do I'll listen to them when I'm like you
know doing dishes and stuff like that
the Tet Zoo podcast and I don't know if
that's even on like Spotify and stuff
but it's tetsu com where you can listen
to that